welcome
hi i'm ram i'm part of the marketplace
platforms at uber
hi i'm nanda i do work in marketplace
platforms at uber
here's our agenda today we'll start with
an overview
of uberscale and some of the key
challenges we are looking to solve
we'll then look at what it took us to
evaluate cloud spanner
and the systems we had to build to
enable our platform on spanner
we'll then deep dive into some technical
learnings
and what we plan to do next let's look
at what scale means at uber
we were started back in 2010 and our
systems have constantly needed to scale
as business has evolved as an engineer
one of the fun things at uber is the
opportunity to build systems at scale
here are some of the numbers based on q1
which essentially highlights
what's the scale of our operations we
did close to 18 million rides
which includes trips and deliveries each
day on the uber platform
we had close to 5 million active drivers
and delivery people
and have close to 103 million monthly
active platform consumers
uber is a global company with a presence
in 10 000 cities
and 69 countries across six continents
from the east side we have 400 000
restaurant partners operating globally
in 45 countries
a scale like this creates a unique set
of technical challenges
the marketplace platform team is
responsible
for the fulfillment platform which
facilitates
the core transportation flows for rides
and needs
we are a huge into microservices
we have a robust infrastructure running
on thousands of nodes
across hundreds of microservices and the
complexity in running so many services
increases as we scale let's look at
a simple example of an offer acceptance
flow
to your left we can see a snapshot
of the offer screen presented to a
driver for a ride strip
the driver has an option to accept or
decline
and from the driver's point of view it's
just top of a button
but a lot of things happen in the
backing these drivers and riders
are modeled as entities in our system
and when state changes occur
all these entities needs to be updated
transactionally
as an example once the driver accepts
the offer
the rider also needs to be associated
with that driver
and all the downstream systems needs to
be updated and kept in sync
also the presented offer needs to auto
expire
if no action has been taken after few
seconds and the feedback for this
also needs to be propagated to
downstream systems
these entities are modeled as state
machines as it undergoes
various entity state transitions from
start to finish of a trip
now this is a very simple example of a
two-sided marketplace
involving a driver and a rider the
complexity increases
with eads which is a three-sided
marketplace involving
a restaurant a delivery person and an
eater
also with some advanced use cases like
trying to batch
more trips together for products like
uberpool and each deliveries
the fulfillment platform handles all
these real-time use cases
so more than a year back we took a
holistic look at our architecture with
an aim to simplify and modernize them
let's look at how we approached we
categorized our challenges
into the following dimensions one was
focused on platform efficiency
and other on data management on platform
efficiency a lot of product teams across
uber
use the fulfillment platform to build
business features
we have to ensure that we build
extensible components across
all our product lines without
introducing complexity
at the same time we want to make sure we
maximize
on our infrastructure efficiency by
improving throughput per core
given the scale of uber even an
incremental improvement here
can have a meaningful impact on the
overall infrastructure spend
from data management point of view our
current application
architecture relies on an eventually
consistent model
and adds complexity at the application
layer to deal with consistency
also when you have so many microservices
state management across
all of them is a huge challenge for our
systems to be reliable we need a
strongly consistent and an available
database
that can scale to our needs and can also
support
complex transactions at scale to
overcome these constraints
we use solutions at application level
like maintaining transaction queues
sticky sharding
along with leveraging ring pop for
coordination
and some patterns around transaction
orchestration
but if you think about it these
application level complexity can be
simplified
with pushing some of them to the
database level
so we classified our database
requirements further into system and
usability aspects
from systems requirement we wanted an
asset compliance system
which can give us finings of
availability and comes with globally
consistent guarantees
uber has multiple data centers so the
solution
should work across data centers and
should satisfy our latency
sls from a usability standpoint we
wanted
support for relational modeling based on
the previous example
we wanted support for a multi-faceted
marketplace where business entities are
highly relational
it should have good observability for
tracking and tracing issues
and should be easy to scale as the
business grows
so with these requirements which are
super high level
in mind the team looked at different
database solutions
we chose cloud spanner for evaluation as
it satisfied all our core requirements
as we started ideating our solution on
top of spanner
we went through a process of identifying
the gaps of what we needed to build
before we could start using spanner
here are some of the things which we
build specific to our use case
pro programming model is highly
asynchronous
and we wanted all our spanner rpcs to be
asynchronous too
for this we built an async spanner
client
so that it can fit into our execution
model
a background task execution system we
built an event sourcing solution on top
of spanner
which we will look into greater detail
further down
ttl as part of a real-time platform
we needed support for ttl so once a trip
ends or an order is fulfilled the data
gets handled by a post-trip
processing platform ttl support is
needed so the data can be cleaned up
once it's no longer needed by the
real-time platform
a transaction execution framework we've
optimized on different strategies for
executing our transactions
and also build tooling around detecting
block contentions and deadlock
lastly for monitoring since all our
metrics are persisted in our internal
systems
some of which are also open source like
n3 and jaeger
we wanted spanner server side metrics
also to be available
internally and closely integrated with
our monitoring and alerting systems
let's look at some of them more closely
we started off with a very lightweight
spanner client
generated using google's open source api
generator
and built on top of grpc this is a java
client
and as mentioned previously this aligns
closely
and well with our async programming
pattern
and also gives us a better handle for
tuning client-side resources
we added more functionality to the
client as part of session
and transaction management to give some
more context
a session acts as a communication
channel and you can only run one
transaction at a time
on a session they are reusable resources
so we build session pooling from ground
up which can auto scale based on usage
for transactions we built different
transaction execution strategies to
reduce our transaction time
more on this later with an example on
observability friend
we wanted to integrate it closely with
our internal observability platforms
like
logging metrics and tracing
to talk more on other systems and
solutions we built
i will hand over to nanda who will take
it from here
thanks ram to give you some context
we wanted a system for executing
background async tasks with at least one
guarantee
we were looking for an event sourcing
solution on top of spanner
such a solution would be used for things
like publishing
internal state change events or to kick
off poster processing like sending
customer notifications for things like
ratings etc
these tasks would be registered as part
of the same transaction as other
entities
for example if the driver has ended the
trip
the task to do post strip processing
would also be registered as part of the
same
interrupt transaction moreover
these tasks also needed to have a timer
property
or they can be scheduled to execute at
some time in future
or they can be scheduled to execute
tasks periodically
to build such a system we introduced a
task table where we
can store all the registered tasks we
then built an efficient scanner
also known as tailors that scans through
this table
and schedules them in memory for
execution
they were named as tailors inspired by
the unix terminology
as the scans only look for new data we
were able to horizontally scale the
system by having multiple tailors across
different shards
so that each scan got its own key space
this approach allowed us to detect any
new tasks for background execution
within milliseconds of them being
registered
another system that we built was a
spanner monitoring service
which is a standalone monitoring service
that imports critical stack driver
metrics into our internal monitoring
stack
the reason why we did why we built this
was to have spanner monitoring well
integrated with our internal systems
especially paging and metric analysis
some of the analysis that we were able
to perform were
session analysis that is to check if
sessions are properly reused and for how
long
than transaction analysis to analyze
long-running transactions
that is spanner provides interesting
stats which allows
us to introspect and dive deeper into
queries and dmls taking longer time
we get this data from spanner and index
it internally making it easier to search
and
analyze building a spanner monitoring
service allowed us to build
also allowed us to build an auto scaler
functionality recently
to scale spanner nodes in an elastic way
based on various server side parameters
like spanner cpu utilization
and storage
while building these systems and testing
spanner at scale we came across some
learnings that we would like to share
that helped us along the way
let's dive deeper technically
the first thing is request patterns so
it's important to have good
understanding of request patterns in
order to come up with the right schema
it is also equally important to
understand how spanner performs reads
and writes
for such a pattern for us we had three
types of patterns
simple crud like operations on a given
row
for such cases completely random primary
key
like uuid works really great it gives us
the best possible distribution and also
avoids hot spots
for multi-row updates or for accessing
related items
use interleave tables it gives locality
with parent rows
ensuring your joints are efficient
the other use case as mentioned before
was to build an efficient scanner that
scans through new rows
frequent road deletions in your table
can cause tombstones which can make your
scans
inefficient causing higher scan
latencies
for such use cases a combination of
shard id
and spanner timestamp works really well
the problem with timestamps in a key
either primary or secondary is that it
can cause hot spots
using shard id prevents the hotspots and
at the same time allows multiple workers
to scan
individual shards in parallel
there were quite a few learnings for us
with respect to how we do transactions
on spanner
so first one was to optimize for
reducing read write transaction time
read write transaction time is measured
as the time between
the first operation in a transaction to
the final operation which is often the
commit
in general increase and read write
transaction time
is equal to increase block contention
and consequently increase in abort rate
in the system
when we started out we had a lot of
aborted transactions because
of log contentions to have deeper
understanding we built a transaction
analyzer tool to identify overlapping
transactions
and dig deeper into each contention
whether it is systemic or whether it's
because of poor request pattern etc
this allowed us to identify the type of
transactions that can be retried on a
bot and the ones that should not
this was important as the last thing you
want is all containing transactions
retrying forever causing more churn and
contentions
for read-only transactions use snapshot
reads wherever possible to increase your
read performance
this allows the reads to be served from
any replicas and consequently reduce the
load on the
leader let's look at an optimization
story with respect to transaction
execution
in the first graph you can see we
started off
with a basic read modified write example
where we read
then write and finally commit
in all there are there were three round
trips to spanner not including the
initial begin transaction as we have a
pool of transactions ready to go
over time our flows got more complex
where we often had to do multiple reads
and writes within a transaction
thus increasing the number of round
trips to spanner
now why does round trip to spanner
matter
depending on where your data center is
each spanner round trip is additional
network latency for example if a
transaction has
five round trips and if network latency
is 30 milliseconds you have lost 150
milliseconds just to the network
as we highlighted earlier uh keeping a
transaction
open for longer also increases the
chances of contention
so to solve for this we systematically
broke down the transaction
by identifying the paths of transaction
that can happen in parallel by building
a transaction graph this allowed us to
issue reads in parallel but writes were
still serialized as the dmls needed to
be in sequence
as illustrated in graph 3 this allowed
us to
reduce the round trips to spanner by
just parallelizing reads
to solve for rights we batched all
rights
and commit together in a single rpc
using the mutations api
as provided by spanner to look at
other learnings with respect to spanner
client side
and server side tunings i will hand it
over to ram
thanks nanda so here are some of the
considerations for client-side
performance and tuning
we'll look at two main aspects to tune
on the client side
sessions and grpc we spoke about
sessions
and session pool as part of session pool
configurations
we recommend to maintain or always
maintain necessary ratio of read write
sessions versus sessions that are used
only for reads a read write session
is a session associated with the
transaction using the begin transaction
api
you can size your session pool based on
the expected workload
and transaction rate also
session management apis like create
sessions and batch create sessions
have high latency it's better to
pre-provision sessions instead of
incurring cost during transaction
operations
on the grpc front we always need to
ensure
to set appropriate deadlines to the grpc
context
we also learned that commit should be
given more time to finish
compared to other operations
for flow control grpc streams are
bi-directional streams
and are mapped to http 2 streams
payloads are serialized as byte streams
which are then fragmented into http 2
frames
grpc uses flow control mechanism in http
2
and this also helps in finer grain
control
for buffering in-flight messages
we optimized our flow control window
depending on our payload size
which we found during our test
compression
this needs to be carefully chosen based
on the payload size
we found our proto payloads are highly
compressible
leading to bandwidth savings currently
only gzip is supported as part of the
grpc
compression codec we recommend on
leveraging grpc
interceptors for observability this can
be plugged into the client for
introspection and tracing
from a server-side tuning point of view
based on our testing we could scale
spanner horizontally
one of the core metric for scaling
spanner nodes is cpu usage
it's recommended to operate below 75
percent
on a smooth cpu usage spanner
operational management is simple
and it's easy to provision more nodes as
and when you need it
it's also important to choose
appropriate regions as spanner offers
variety of options
like namthry namsex and regional spanner
instances
on the network side since we run our
infrastructure
in our own data center it's important to
have an optimized routing strategy to
span a server
we work with gcp to make this happen
on the database workload spanner
performs database splits and compactions
based on traffic this can be a load or a
size based split
which might have a brief impact on
latency it's important to have an
appropriate ramp up strategy
so that there is minimal disruptions
during the split
with all these learnings and
optimizations and along with the support
of the systems we built
we performed simulations on spanner with
a synthetic
uber scale load before we look at these
numbers
it's important to understand these are
strictly dependent on data modeling
and how transactions are run this is
highly use case specific
and might not apply to every use case
here are the following highlights we are
able to scale spanner nodes horizontally
to more than 600 nodes with a 330 000
per second reads per second and 130
000 writes per second
cpu usage stayed close to 67 percent
and in terms of latency we mainly cared
about the following rpcs
execute sql execute batch dml and commit
latency
which were within our acceptable latency
requirements
we were also working on a bunch of more
optimizations to perform
better the performance
so what are we doing next we're looking
towards building out new features
like forecasting or spanner nodes based
on
predicted load and optimize on cpu usage
we're also looking forward to testing
few spanner features like
backup and restore we will also look at
open sourcing some of our work
in the future lastly
as we are working on productionizing our
platform on cloud spanner there's a
whole team behind this
and lots of people are involved both on
uber and from google cloud team
as we embark on this journey we are
looking forward to this continued
collaboration
and partnership on behalf of nanda
i thank you for watching the talk